hydrogen has been hailed as a fuel of
the future that could help end the
world's dependence on fossil fuels
and aid the transition to net zero
emissions
but for this hydrogen revolution to take
place some big obstacles need to be
overcome
so is the hype about hydrogen justified
[Music]
hydrogen is the most abundant element in
the universe
it's essential for life
the sun is mostly made of it
and it's present in almost all living
things
but on earth pure hydrogen is very
scarce
instead it mainly exists combined with
oxygen in the form of water
so how does this abundant element get
turned into a fuel that could help save
the planet
first hydrogen needs to be obtained this
is done by splitting molecules
hydrogen is an energy carrier unlike
let's say petroleum which is a primary
energy source you have to make hydrogen
from something
to do this requires an input of energy
you can use methane through a process
called steam reforming
or a source of electricity through
electrolysis once you have some hydrogen
you can either burn it directly or mix
it with oxygen in a fuel cell which is
rather like a battery
the reaction in the fuel cell produces
electricity and heat
and the only waste is water one of the
benefits of hydrogen in a hydrogen
vehicle let's say the only emission that
comes out of the tailpipe is pure
drinkable water in contrast of course to
the internal combustion engine which
puts out loads of nasty chemicals and
carcinogens
this means that as long as the energy
used to produce it is sustainable
hydrogen can be a truly green fuel
[Music]
nasa started using hydrogen fuel cells
to generate electricity in its space
capsules in the 1960s
today it's not just being considered as
a rocket fuel in space but also for
planes trains and automobiles as well as
the industrial sector
the most likely early applications are
going to be in heavy industry for
example uh steel and cement making these
are heavy heavy greenhouse gas polluters
and they consume lots of energy a lot of
coal in particular
and it's very hard to replace that with
electricity which is probably how most
of the decarbonization of the global
economy will happen
this isn't the first time hydrogen has
been hailed as a fuel of the future
so why has it never taken off
[Music]
until renewables existed at scale making
hydrogen required vast amounts of fossil
fuel or nuclear energy which made
hydrogen both more expensive and less
efficient than other ways of storing and
delivering energy
until climate change moved up the
political agenda hydrogen simply wasn't
worth it
the existing fossil fuel infrastructure
has been in place for decades
it's trillions of dollars of invested
legacy equipment
and the companies that built it defend
their assets
and so it makes it very difficult for
governments to force that legacy
equipment to be pushed aside in favor of
radically new rival equipment like
hydrogen infrastructure or for that
matter renewable energy
the passengers look down to see the east
coast of america gliding by beneath them
there has also been a battle against
public perception of hydrogen safety
sparked by the hindenburg disaster in
1937.
within seconds there was a terrific
explosion aft and brilliant orange
flames formed the backdrop for a tableau
of death hydrogen gas is very flammable
and does need to be stored in a specific
way
but fears about its safety are overblown
[Music]
the hindenburg
did not explode because of the hydrogen
it's been shown that's a misperception
and what's more industry has shown that
hydrogen vehicles can be safer than
internal combustion vehicle cars that
use gasoline which of course is an
explosive product
across the world a hydrogen every day is
used by industry perfectly safely
one advantage hydrogen has over
batteries is that it's much more energy
dense which means that with a very high
pressure storage system it takes much
less space in order to make a vehicle go
any distance
if you have a hydrogen tank on board a
vehicle you can refuel quickly compared
to batteries and electric cars
but
we do have issues of cost we have issues
of refueling stations and fueling
infrastructure that have to be built out
so that's another obstacle that stands
in the way of hydrogen
there's also a question over how
sustainable hydrogen really is
despite some advances in the technology
to generate it it still requires
energy-intensive processes that are
fueled largely by fossil fuels or lots
of electricity
the only way to make truly green
hydrogen is to reduce it using
sustainable energy
at the moment a lot of the hydrogen
that's used in the world is made from
natural gas but that does produce some
greenhouse gas emissions some people see
this as terrible and other people say
this could be a bridge it can help build
the market until there's enough
renewable energy and electrolyzers
become more efficient and
more cost effective
but even if renewable energy is used in
the electrolysis process the energy
content that comes out is less than what
goes in which leads some to argue that
hydrogen is just a waste of renewable
energy
they have a point there are a lot of
applications in which electricity is
simply the best thing to use and more
efficient but there are other
applications in heavy industry
particularly or long distance transport
for example where hydrogen could find a
niche and quite a big niche
unlike earlier waves of enthusiasm
hydrogen fuel could be here to stay this
time
technological advances are making
hydrogen production more efficient and
cheaper
and this along with government's
commitment to decarbonise is helping
drive a new hydrogen economy
we see huge improvements in the vehicles
or the processes that use hydrogen and
we see much more sophistication among
the companies that are using it
according to a study by mckinsey there
are more than 350 large-scale global
projects underway right now
the projected total investment in the
hydrogen sector amounts to an estimated
500 billion dollars
we're seeing much more interest from
venture capitalists uh entrepreneurial
activity scientific advances moving from
the laboratories to pilot plants and
ultimately getting towards the
marketplace because they know a market
that will pay for low carbon approaches
or green hydrogen is coming
germany has announced a 7 billion euro
program and the chinese government wants
to have 1 million fuel cell powered
vehicles on its roads by 2030
when we think about the tools that are
needed to get to a net zero carbon world
there's no doubt that hydrogen will play
a role in the short term electrification
is going to lead the decarbonization
charge but longer term i think there is
a great potential for a real hydrogen
revolution that would play a big role in
a decarbonized society i'm vijay vadis
warren the economist global energy and
climate innovation editor
to keep up to date with all of our
climate change coverage
please click on the link
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe